the tampa bay buccaneers whose
quarterback
directly or indirectly contributed to
the situation in green bay because tom
brady is treated exactly the way aaron
rodgers would like to be treated up to
it including getting a phone call yes a
phone call before they drafted a
quarterback in round two this year when
they took kyle trask brady
at the bucks mandatory minicamp here's
coach bruce aries talking about how his
starting quarterback who is there and
happy to be there performed
they look fine i had to pull him out a
couple i didn't the first period was
okay you can have four they kept begging
to go back in but uh only thing i didn't
want him in was the blitz period where
you know some guys might get around him
to too quick yeah the doctors and him
you know they both they both said he was
he was good to go and
it would still be careful with what
we're doing with him and
but
yeah trying to stop him from playing is
is pretty tough
erin's also said they're planning for
more work out of the shotgun as brady
continues to recover from this knee
surgery hey they're they're in a
delicate spot here
because
brady himself said it was pretty serious
knee surgery there was a report well hey
when we find out the details we're going
to be amazed at how tom brady was able
to thrive
despite this knee that the left knee the
same one that had the torn acl first
game of the 2008 season the surgery on
it how big of a deal it was because if
you do that too much you're going to get
fined by the nfl because he never showed
up on the injury report with a knee
injury last year but just the fact that
that this thing has them
revamping their offense to protect that
knee after surgery it tells you it was a
big deal chris yeah there's no question
i mean it's on their mind certainly you
know and i what i'm like what i'm like
kind of interested and want to see is is
even when his knee starts to feel better
is this something that they're gonna
start doing more to the shotgun you know
i could see them doing that to a degree
now we showed the stats i mean under
center was pretty good right and last
year i mean towards the end of the year
how many like i mean
how much did we talk about under the
center play action pass
look how deadly they are as a football
team you see the touchdowns interception
ratio 8.7 yards per attempt that's a
pretty good number i mean you know that
that play-action pass was a key to them
winning the super bowl it really was now
they could do it out of the shotgun but
as we talked about you know before i
don't think this is as effective play
action pass out of the shotgun it's why
i think you're gonna we're gonna see the
baltimore ravens lamar jackson they're
talking about infusing getting
underneath the center more but also mike
here's the thing the injury
you know what i i've actually lost track
what is he going to be 45 this year you
know 44. 44 august 3. getting underneath
the center dropping back doing all that
that will wear your legs out that's
there's no joke there's not i bet you
there's a part of brady that's a little
bit like man i'm gonna be 44. i wouldn't
mind you know you saving me and all
these run plays and play action plays
and everything i got to do would get low
get underneath the center drive out do
all that stuff man it'd take a little
wear and tear off me if i could just sit
here in the shotgun and be in the spot
already and do it and wheel and deal
that way that's where i'm interested to
see if it really becomes a
a real thing within the offense you know
consist consistently throughout the year
we've stopped saying it because he
continues to defy
the biology yeah of it but father time
remains undefeated at some point tom
brady will not be able to do the things
he does when we see him do them
we say well i guess he'll be able to
keep doing him forever
he can play till he's 50.
i had that thought last year holy crap
look at this guy at 43.
maybe he has found the the fountain of
youth in florida and he's just going to
keep going and
who don't bet against him and he's
determined and you know at some point at
some point
the car is going to run out of gas yeah
i know it will happen right and and and
what was always told to me and this has
now been four years ago watch his legs
we've talked about this watch his legs
the arm's fine and we'll be fine once
the legs start to go
that's when he starts getting hit that's
when he starts getting hurt that's when
he wakes up one day to take it all back
to lawrence taylor remember when
lawrence taylor got to the end of his
career he said to bill parcells man all
these young guys are really fast
no
no they're not fast right you're so slow
yeah yeah and at some point you know
when you can't duck and cover when you
got frank clark coming at you full speed
ahead and you take that hit that's when
it's going to end quickly and you fall
off a cliff at that point so that's i
you know even though i've gotten numb to
that because he keeps going and going
and going that possibility still looms
out there that when it ends it's going
to end quickly it's we've seen inklings
you know again now he's done the the
greatest job in the history of this the
sport preserving his body prolonging it
doing those things and then hey his move
from new england to tampa was masterful
he put himself and again another place
that you know kind of extends the
lifeline of his career great offensive
line you know
he doesn't have to put himself out there
physically with like a rebuilding team
and get beat up and do things like that
so that's where he has been awesome and
bought himself time we talked about his
arm being he's going to be able to throw
lasers when he's 55 but i think your
thing about the legs and all that is
still spot on and let's not forget
you know the first 10 weeks of the year
last year we had some moments of going
like oh it was a little shaky and we
definitely have seen moments of when you
get pressure right the fourth down when
you get pressure and things like that
there is still a reluctancy to get hit
and i say that not to be disrespectful
because brady is one of the toughest
sobs ever to play quarterback but we saw
it the green bay game there's a blitz
nobody even hits him he's falling down
he just throws it in the air there was a
number of those plays last year to at
least no
wait you see he's very conscious of not
getting hit or trying to save himself
that way and those are at least inklings
but you know he still keeps answering
the bell and doing awesome like you're
talking about
that mentality has been around for
several years it has though
because it was it was that game his last
year at the patriots they had a chance
to tie it up and instead of standing in
there taking the hit and delivering the
strike to julian edelman in the end zone
he did the duck and cover and get rid of
it and roll away and that's look the guy
is playing
starting quarterback in the nfl
at an age beyond which anyone ever has
and one of the ways you survive at that
point that's right avoid getting hit
and and he's avoiding getting hit at the
expense of his performance
when when the packers had the door blow
open down 28 to 10
and he has three interceptions i mean
just think of what the narrative all
year long
from february until now would have been
if the buccaneers are up 28 to 10 in the
nfc championship game against aaron
rodgers right and they go for it instead
of kick the field goal right tie the
game up win the game in overtime tom
brady blows an 18-point lead with three
interceptions and that's the last we see
of him his first year with the
buccaneers and that's what sinks in yeah
and that's what we're all talking about
oh and he has serious knee surgery right
is this the end is he ever going to be
the same right that's the conversation
would be there's no doubt and we would
be going back and visiting the the
blunders that would happen during the
year he wouldn't be doing videos making
fun of himself for the four-finger thing
all of those it would be it just shows
you sport everything like it it's
amazing you know that was in the balance
there you're exactly right two guys
careers two teams in a totally different
way you know we would be talking about
these moments about you know the
slippage to your point and this would be
part of the point part of the part of
the reason we would bring it up yeah
plays like this we never saw brady do
this physically all that what what this
is gratuitous but it's fine because it's
not me no
i i have no problem with gratuitous
insults as long as they're not directed
at me yeah and even when they are
sometimes they're funny i'm okay with it
but yeah i mean it really is amazing
that one decision
by matt leflore
and who who knows maybe they wouldn't
have gotten that yeah no they wouldn't
have rushed over time maybe they
wouldn't win the game but the momentum
was swung in their direction it was tom
brady had three interceptions yeah it
would have been
it would have been an epic meltdown i
mean really it would have been one of
the all-time meltdowns we would have
said if green bay did come back to win
that game and then of course you know
where would aaron rodgers and that
relationship be with green bay if they
did get to the super bowl and everything
it just it changed the whole dynamic of
the nfl 2021 season
all because of the nfc championship game
and the last five you know last quarter
of that game really dictated a lot of
what we talk about this offseason
oh yeah i mean now it's all hey the
bucks won the super bowl they got all
the starters back yeah it goes
undefeated right yeah that would
definitely not be the vibe if they had
if they had crashed and burned the way
they could have and some would say
should have against the green bay pack
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports